hi i'm melissa laird smith
i recently joined the department of
biochemistry molecular genetics at the
university of louisville
and i'm really excited today to share
with all of you
some newer data on leveraging smart
sequencing to resolve complex immune
loci
to thank the organizers for this
invitation
so just to bring everyone up to speed so
that we're all speaking a common
language
the immune response is a carefully
coordinated multicellular and
multi-organ cascade developed to detect
anything that's non-self so this
includes pathogens parasites
as well as what could be considered
non-self cells such as cancer
now broadly the immune system is divided
into two arms the innate and the
adaptive arm
innate immunity is quite rapid and it
responds to generalized motifs that are
called
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
these are
molecular patterns that are found in
non-eukaryotic organisms and these
mechanisms are carried out by the cells
represented in the purple circle in that
overlapping venn diagram on the bottom
left
the adaptive immune system arises much
quicker
with some time after the innate response
is mounted and is much more specific it
has a very high accuracy to the specific
pathogen of interest
the mechanisms of the adaptive immune
system are carried out by b
and t cells represented in the red then
on the la
on the left and the right of the
left-handed figure
it takes some time for this immune
system arm to come up
a few days to a few weeks after
infection
but when it is available it detects and
targets as
particularly pathogens with exquisite
specificity
so b and t cells which make up the
adaptive immune system function to seek
and destroy through any means possible
so what i'm just showing you here is an
overview of how these cells function
b cells specifically produce antibodies
and it's the antibodies that are the
effector molecules of that arm of the
immune system
we don't need to go into great detail
about all the different functions that
antibodies can
perform in the context of immune
response just to know that they are
myriad
and they are specialized t cells also
have a very specialized route of attack
and the t cell population can be divided
very broadly into two classes
cd4 or helper t cells and cd8 or
cytotoxic t cells
so they act directly or indirectly to
clear non-self so i'm showing you a
schematic of cd8
t cell action here in the top right
these cells
after recognizing antigen very
specifically will release
enzymes and perforin to directly destroy
infected cells
cd4 cells on the other hand detect
antigen
and then produce helper molecules or
signaling
assistance to spur other parts of the
immune system these cd4 cells
can be pro-inflammatory
anti-inflammatory or regulatory
but together their antigen specificity
allows us to
um clear pretty much anything that comes
to our system
now how is that possible i mean we can't
predict what pathogens will encounter in
our lifetime and so
genomically our system is built in a way
to
create the level of variation that makes
it possible for us to detect anything we
may encounter
so overall it's done with incredibly
complex genomics that's sort of the
the cut to the cut to the cheese event
message the long story of that is this
is done through the expression of
multiple haplotypes
extensive recombination mechanisms and
selective a hypermutation
as necessary so in the case of b cells
and honestly t cell receptors as well
this variation is is introduced through
the recombination of specific
v d and j segments at these immune loci
for any of you that have had immune
classes immunology classes in the past
this can bring back a few flashbacks
it's quite a complex system we don't
need to understand it
thoroughly today but the idea is that
any one of the
up to 100 v segments can recombine with
any one of the many of these segments
and then any one of the j
segments to create a vdj a recombined
fragment that then encodes the variable
region
that detects uh the pathogen of interest
the fact that there are many many
segments in each of these pools creates
a combinatorial diversity
uh that produces that level of variation
needed
to detect anything that we may see upon
infection
furthermore in b cells there's an
additional mechanism of somatic
hypermutation
that um happens after the b cell has
detected an antigen that increases the
affinity and
ability and affinity uh for these
antibodies uh to the antigen of interest
key cells on the other hand sort of have
a a two part
system in order to detect the
specificity of an antigen there is the t
cell receptor which as i mentioned
previously acts similar to the b cell
receptor
generating combinatorial diversity
through pdj recombination
but the t cell receptor only detects
pathogens uh when they are bound to the
human leukocyte antigen molecule or hla
so you have the opportunity of diversity
on both sides both at the t-cell side
as well as the host side that's
expressing hla now hla
is a multi-gene a region of the genome
divided into class 1 class 2 and class 3
genes
they're represented on that bar graph on
the right and each one of these genes
has uh hundreds if not thousands of
alleles that have been characterized
in the populations around the world and
so there's this incredible amount of
haploid
diversity that provides an additional
level of variation when combined with
the highly variable t cell receptors
so the difference is here is that b
cells generate diversity on a cell by
cell basis
every b cell undergoes bdj recombination
and every leading j recombination event
that happens
is assumed to be slightly different
hla itself is fixed to a diverse array
of haplotypes
but the diversity of those haplotypes
and the combinatorial diversity of those
haplotypes
is incredible given the number of
alleles that we know exist
and then when you combine that with the
fact that these hla molecules have to
interact with the t-cell receptors
you get a very high level of diversity
i'm going to pause for a moment with
sort of the immunology background and
talk about
single molecule real-time sequencing so
the
uh the the direct impact of single
molecule real-time sequencing is the
long reads that are capable of being
generated by their specific
preliminaries
um and and what happens when you
generate a smart
library is that you take a
double-stranded dna molecule
you like it on smart adapters which are
essentially hair pins
and what that does is change your linear
sequence template into a circular
template for sequencing
the polymerase as i mentioned is
incredibly processive and
i'm capable of generating very long read
links so when you have a
fixed insert of a specific size of your
double-stranded dna molecule
but a very processive polymerase what
happens is that polymerase goes around
and around and around the molecule
in order to create multiple passes over
both the forward and the reverse strands
once that is done we can use those
forward and reverse strands to collapse
into a highly accurate circular
consensus sequence or
high fidelity or high fire read and it's
these reads that are used for downstream
analysis so the
um the reason that we use these reads
for the immune loci
is that these reads can both generate
sequences over
long molecules as well as incredibly
high accurate at
high accuracy so in the case of
immunoglobulin heavy chain locus so this
is a critical component of the antibody
um we can use these long reads to
assemble
a highly accurate but large region of
the genome so this genome
genomic region is about one megabase and
in the instance that i'm going to show
you today
we use the custom target enrichment
method that uses
8 kb overlapping fragments to assemble
this locus with high accuracy and able
to generate distinct haplotypes from
each individual
the reason that the long reads are so
powerful here is that this is a region
full of structural variants
and when you use short reads uh they
don't capture the entirety of the
structural variant within a short read
and therefore cannot accurately map
when you use these larger reads
generated by smart sequencing with the
high accuracy that's produced by the
high fire reads
you get a very clear picture of where
insertions and deletions lie in fact if
you look
at the assembled haplotype in line two
in that figure you can see a set of
black boxes in the middle
of that haplotype that represents the
deletion in that individual that's not
seen
in the parallel individuals in this
figure and that was able to be captured
by a single molecule read and
firmly mapped to that region of the
locus
in the case of hla which i'll talk about
today the the genes themselves range
from three to about seven kb
we can capture them the entirety of the
gene in a single high fi read so no
assembly required no bioinformatic
computation
and we can get highly accurate
resolution of the full sequence
introns and axons in a single read so
i'm going to start today by talking
about hla
luckily there is a commercially
available robust workflow for the
full-length resolution of hla alleles
without imputation so let's start a
little bit with background why hla is
important as i mentioned hla and t-cell
receptors interact to activate and
modulate the t-cell response
specifically class 1 is expressed in
most nucleated cells and it presents
antigens to 78 positive t
cells with the appropriate secondary
signaling the hla class 1 and t cell
receptor interaction on cdht cells
triggers that cytotoxic t cell activity
to clear non-self directly
in the case of class 2 these molecules
interact with t cell receptors on that
cd4 t cell population
class 2 is expressed only on what are
considered professional antigen
presenting cells macrophage
dendritic cells and b cells and they
present antigens to t cell receptors on
cd4 positive t
cells appropriate signaling uh within
the context of this interactions
triggers those helper responses
production of cytokines
or b cell help so classifying and
characterizing these hla haplotypes
in individuals is very important for
understanding the progression of disease
it's been shown in several disease
models that particular haplotypes and
hoa can offer either a protective or
even in some cases a detrimental effect
on your ability to mount an effective
t-cell response so
understanding the hla haplotypes
expressed in individuals that
present a diversity of responses to in
response to infections like covid
it's critically important for
understanding what role t-cell responses
and hla restriction are imposing
on the ability to actually clear these
types of infections
so the company gen dx actually provides
a commercially available proprietary hla
amplification protocol in really amazing
downstream informatics tools to analyze
this providing sort of an end-to-end
workflow from sample
through analysis of hla haplotyping this
original workflow was designed for short
read sequencing on aluminum
instrumentation
so we've adapted it to work with the
pack bios systems
so when we get these kits in the
workflows we do not use any of the
library prep reagents that come from
gendx we use the
biosmart belt kits but we do use the the
primers in order to analyze
and amplify the specific hla genes of
interest
now uh gen dx has primers available that
can amplify up to 12 different hilly
loci uh which is great
and often you have to buy these in
separate primer sets and actually
amplify genes one by one
what's been really great is in the past
few years they've started developing
multiplex
amplicon pools and in this case in the
data i'll show you today we use the pool
called mx61
this uh amplifies six different hla loci
highlighted here in the pink square
uh specifically three class uh
one alleles hla a b and c and three
class two alleles drb1 the qb1
and dpv1 but it does it in a single pcr
reaction limiting
the use or overuse of precious patient
samples
so our workflow looks like this we use a
250 nanograms of
genomic dna this has to be high quality
it can't be formal in fixed tissue
or form olympic dna we put this into the
mx61 gendx pcr reaction again that
amplifies six loci in a single pcr
once those amplicons are amplified we
generate uh
smart bell libraries in the pack by a
library prep we do this using barcoded
smart balls so that hairpin adapter
that you like it onto your double
stranded dna molecule in this case
contains a unique barcode that separates
multiple
individuals into one pool so in our case
we've been doing 48 plex reactions
each one of these 48 flex pools is
sequenced on one smart cell on the sql
system
i'm using the smart cell 1m once the
data is generated
we de-multiplexed this data and generate
those highly accurate hi-fi reads
and we have a resultant fasta file that
we use for downstream analysis
in the ngs engine software provided by
gen dx
so hla is typed at multiple different
levels
um sort of a eight digit identification
gives us the highest resolution
uh definition of what that hla allele
looks like and using these highly
accurate
single molecule reads which phases the
entire molecule windows
into a single read allows us the highest
resolution data for these hla
alleles per individual so what i'm
showing you there is sort of that
the take-home message of a haplotyping
on a patient sample where you get eight
digit resolution of both alleles across
all six loci using that ngs engine
software with those high firings
so as i mentioned we use 200 to 250
total genomic dna
input for that amplification um we get
out of that amplification about 100
nanograms per microliter of amplified
material per sample this obviously
varies widely per sample and patient
and about 150 milligrams of that
amplified product will be used as input
into the library prep
this is what these libraries look like
this is a bioanalyzer trace using the
12k
dna chip the amplification itself is
incredibly robust the libraries are very
consistent and can easily be pooled
without being worried about differential
molarity
we do this pooling manually at this
point although our hope is eventually
automated um and then we sequence on the
on the smart cell on the sql system
so this is just some raw data from one
of these runs and really the point i
want to make is in the graph on the far
right so in this graph on the y-axis you
have what's called base density so this
is the
number of bases that are found in each
wavelength bin
and across the x-axis you have that read
length thinning
and what i want to point out to you are
the the
two areas of the curve that are shaded
by the two darker blue colors this marks
the 50
marker and 50 where 50 of the bases lie
in reads of a certain length or above
so 50 of our bases in this in this run
lie in reads of over 170 kb
which means if you have a 5kb uh insert
and you get 170 kb read that's gone
around and around and around that 5kb
instead you're getting
many many many tens if not hundreds of
passes of your molecule to generate the
most highly accurate reads for
downstream analysis
so as i mentioned we demux barcodes
generate those hi-fi reads and put them
into nvs engine
ngs engine is an incredibly powerful
software
it provides a number of different
critical criteria as you're analyzing
your data
including the map ability of the data
the overall rate length of your
molecules the depth per locus which is
somewhat skewed due to amplification
bias that gen dx manages within their
amplification schema
and then the actual genotypes and
haplotypes of the
of the samples you're looking at um
you'll notice i just want to highlight
two particular points
so the map ability the far left column
is in that
parenthesis the percentage of reads that
map to your locus
with our hi-fi reads we routinely see
between 95
and 100 percent of the reads mapping to
the locus that's an incredibly
high high map ability in fact as of
comparable alumina data
is in the in the high 80s to low 90s so
these hifi reads are outperforming
sort of the standard pipeline that gendx
itself
recommends moreover you can take these
data and generate
a pdf report which is a great way to
organize your data and it includes an
incredible amount of information so it
includes the allylic
calls that are made as you can see here
in this screenshot of page one as any
as well as any um alternate fields that
could be
uh possible in your data given the
ambiguity of some of the higher
resolution reads
due to database issues with the hla
population
i mean it also shows you the the sort of
signal-to-noise ratio of your reads and
the map ability
um on the locus of interest as well as
the snip variation across that locus
um for all six alleles and most
importantly it gives you again
the map ability the number of reads that
match your locus so again we're getting
you know between 95 and 100
read map ability which is which is
incredible so overall
using the gen dx um molecular reagents
and software
combined with the power of the
long-range sequencing we're able to do
very robust a high-throughput hla typing
with the highest resolution technologies
possible
um this has been incredible for covid
studies lately as well as as applicable
to any
um any studies where you think
characterizing the hla restriction of
your disease of interest would be
would be useful so the next thing i want
to talk about quickly is
a is the genotyping strategy that i've
been working on with my colleague here
at the university of louisville dr corey
watson
to develop a sort of a parallel to hle
genotyping but in this case for the
immunoglobulin most size so again
these are the loci that control the
recombination
and encoding of our b-cell receptors or
antibodies
um as as part of the b-cell response so
the genomic complexity of the igh locus
is extensive and it's poorly
characterized
so we know again that these regions are
generated through recombination of
variable
um the vdj region to create that
variable region
we just don't know what the population
variation of these genes are
there are only two references in the
database i'm showing you a schematized
version of the first reference here
and i'm going to layer on top of the
second reference and what you can see is
that with only these two references
there's a huge amount of diversity
so across these two references we were
able to see that our corey was able to
see that over 50 percent of igh sequence
falls within a large segmental
duplication
copy number variants are highly
prevalent and again they've only been
sequenced twice
and neither of these samples are
actually a full viable diploid human
individual
and so it really is thought that many
genes are not represented in the current
assemblies
now earlier genomics methods such as g
watt study g-raw studies have really
limited the utility
of assessing the role of igh in disease
progression due to the fact
that so so little information is known
about the locus so what i'm showing in
this schema
is um the microarray mapping
of all it goes across all 23 human
chromosomes
and what you can see is that the hla
region which we just spoke of there's
many many variants that are known to be
in that locus and in fact
uh over 9 000 snips are represented in
some of these immune arrays so the
arrays are ready to capture
variation associated with disease in
this locus even the cure region which is
responsible for nk cell
uh recognition and activity which is
also thought to be somewhat of a black
box in the genome
um in these types of immune arrays over
800 snips are represented
whereas if you look at igh there are
only five
so if you think about the data that i
just showed you between just those two
haplotypes just those two references we
observed
over 2500 snips so if there are only
five snips represented in arrays then
you're going to really lose the ability
to associate variance in this locus with
disease
when they're performed with these large
geos studies that came sort of
in the generation before application
next generation sequencing
but we know that that allylic diversity
is there a lot of investigators in this
space
use immune profiling sequencing the b
cell receptors
to extrapolate and impute what the what
the germline
variation of these vdj genes are and we
see that both there are a number
a vast number of alleles in each of
these genes somewhat like the hla
parallel i spoke of before
as well um as possible new alleles that
haven't been discovered or recorded in
the database
so overall the motivation of this
project was to understand the true
extent of population diversity and see
if we could build out an
assay that could measure that in any
sample you know we firmly believe that
the lack of data in this locus has a
huge impact on any disease association
studies
a development of diagnostic and
therapeutic strategies that depend on an
antibody response for their efficacy
as well as functional studies again that
depend on antibodies for their advocacy
so the aims of this project were first
to expand the reference database
such that we could incorporate
ethnically diverse haplotypes into the
design of our genotyping assay
and then that is aimed too to develop a
genotyping assay to be utilized sort of
allah the hla essay i just showed you
to investigate the impact of hl of igh
allylic diversity
and correlate that as a function of
disease um disease progression and
vaccine efficacy
so the first thing we did again aim one
was to generate some additional
haplotypes
the two references that are in the
database are both caucasian derived so
we also wanted to include an ethnically
diverse array of samples
to see how the variation of these locus
differ amongst populations worldwide
and so we did this using a number of
samples that have been well
characterized
in the thousand genomes project and have
had
previously a fosmid libraries generated
uh
from them in the evan iqr lab and so we
did this we sequenced these phosmic
libraries specifically across the igh
focus
so in this case we took these plasmids
which are about 40 kb
we sheared them and generated smartbelt
libraries
these were sequenced on the rs2 this
project has been happening since about
2016. so the system was a bit older
and then we used that data to tile
across and build out these haplotypic
references for igh
so this is a schematic of just the v
genes
within that immunoglobulin heavy chain
locus these are the two references i
showed you earlier
schematize in a linear fashion so just
to give you a little bit
of a groundwork um each one of these
boxes represents a distinctive gene
the color of the box represents the
number of alleles
in that gene in this individual so what
you can see
even between the two references that
there are pretty big drastic differences
both in
the copy number variance at each vgen
allele but also
few more gross structural variants like
deletions so in the hg19 reference on
the bottom you have that deletion on the
far
right end that doesn't exist in hg-38
and the other deletions are shifted
around the locus
so we added six additional references so
we
more than triple the number of
references that are available
um and these references were generated
from samples
sourced from your reuben populations in
africa
both a chinese and a japanese sample
from asia as well as two additional
european samples
and again you can see a vast amount of
variation both in the allylic diversity
represented by the colors of the boxes
in the vertical rows of the same gene
placement position
as well as in these gross large
structural variants the european samples
and our two
references include that large deletion
in the middle of the locus
whereas the african and asian samples
don't include that deletion at all
and that's uh quite interesting if we're
trying to generate
vaccines targeting uh specific alleles
we need to make sure that those alleles
are present
in our populations of interest what's
also notable are the yellow squares so
the yellow squares are novel igh alleles
that haven't been seen in the database
before
so when these um assemblies were
completed we were able to submit
to imgt the immunogenetics database
a number of new alleles had not been
previously observed
as well as characterize a huge number of
unique snips to each
to each of these new references that
could be
variants affecting expression of
downstream antibodies
so using these data together we designed
a novel capture panel
to act as the genotyping assays you
could actually apply this method
and characterize the igh genotypes in
any sample that you happen to have
so in this case we're generating uh six
to eight pb
uh genomic dna fragments we're capturing
them with an igh specific
oligopole and then generating a pet
biosequencing library
and sequencing them assembling them and
changing paper types
and when we do that here are two
examples we can actually generate
phased haplotypic resolution of the igh
so that entire one megabase region we
can separate out the maternal and
paternal allele
as well as the genes that vary between
them
for uh for analysis so these are two
again
thousand genome sample that we used to
benchmark this paper actually just got
accepted in frontiers uh of immunology
about two to those we're quite excited
to get this out
in the field um we also benchmarked uh
so these
these thousand genome samples because
there's so much aluminum data that have
been generated with them we were able to
benchmark on that illumina data the
performance of our assay
as well as a lot of singer sequencing
data as well and when you do that level
of benchmarking
and you look at the comparison to ground
truth uh which was the singer sequencing
we see that we get fall far fewer false
positives and false negatives of
variance called with our tool which is
called igenotyper which is a custom
analytics tool to take this capture data
and call these haplotypes in the igh
locus than you do when you use
some of the existing illumina amputation
software the snips that were identified
between the thousand genomes project
and igenotyper using the short versus
long reads vary there are some overlaps
but some of them are also very unique
so the implication of these data is is
pretty tremendous um
you know we don't again we don't know a
lot about this locus across populations
so even just
understanding population genomics at
that level is new and interesting
but the power of it here is whereas
people have been imputing
uh allele usage in in genotypes from
rna data this essay actually captures
all of it at the dna level so it
captures the coding regions of those
vdnj genes
but it also captures the intergenic
regions which actually contain very
critical
signal sequences which can impact the
ability to express these genes
in the form of an antibody response so
we are now set up to do
uh and are performing now match the dna
and rna experiments where we genotype an
individual we do the immune repertoire
sequencing and look and see how these
two things are influenced and if there
are variants in the dna
that are affecting your ability to
express particular antibodies
which could be critical for evaluating
the efficacy of a vaccine
so in conclusion we firmly believe that
resolution of complex immune loci is
significantly improved when you utilize
long single molecule sequencing
approaches
full-length genes can actually
accurately be captured as single
molecules which negates any need for
bioinformatics
imputation or reconstruction assembly of
longer region is greatly enhanced by the
ability to phase haplotypic snips across
much longer molecules
when they're assembled and long beads
capture the full structural variants in
their surrounding context which helps
avoid mismapping
and allowing the resolution of copy
number variants which may be captured
within a single molecule or large
insertions and deletions
which in which reads that are generated
with smaller read technologies may not
be able to accurately map
end-to-end hla genotyping pipelines are
available
and when you combine those with long
reads it creates a robust commercially
available
mid to high throughput end-to-end
solution on the sql systems
we're quite excited to increase our
throughput on the sql 2
system that was just that we just
purchased here in louisville
and we are developing novel igh
genotyping strategies uh
with custom analytics support in the
form of the igenotyper software
which will allow for the interrogation
of full locus variation in any sample of
interest
now i really like to end my talks with
sort of a take-home message
um and uh at a meeting last year i was i
was challenged to create a sort of a
seven word challenge so can you
summarize your talk in seven words that
the listeners can take home with you
so my seven word challenge for this talk
is that long reads resolve the
complexity underlying disease and
theology
so i'm going to wrap it up by
acknowledging
and thanking extensively my
collaborators as i mentioned i recently
joined the university of louisville only
within the last
month or so very excited to work side by
side with corey watson who i've been
working with to do the igh work thus far
um and we are very excited and proud new
owners of a sql 2 system and will be
enrolling in the certified service
provider program with pac bio shortly
um and so if you're interested at all in
exploring either of these options please
don't hesitate to reach out
thank you very much